the oceans just buried the family
matriarch Rosalind was 87 years old when
she died but they claim her death was
asked by high exposure to oil pollution
he make up the four sick and you take
her to Clinic you do this before she
died we are spending money on her health
because of the water
Mercy is covered in skin rashes she says
it's from ingesting and bathing in
contaminated water
Royal Dutch Shell has been producing oil
in ogoni land since 1958. the organic
Community is now suing it for
environmental damages
is a man leading the charge against the
old giant he says his community feels
betrayed by shell
I am devastated
that that option now
shell is trying to see how they can hide
away from this what royal dochel did in
orgalee
they killed our people they are still
killing our people so those who are
making profit or those who have made
profit out of this need to know that it
is blood Money
they say the devastation caused by
almost 70 years of oil exploration in
Nigeria's Niger Delta is massive
thousands of hectares of mangroves land
and water sources have been damaged
it's estimated it could take between 30
to 50 years to restore the polluted
sites to what they were before
more than 50 oil spills have been
recorded in ogalli and Billy communities
polluting farms and rivers contaminating
fish stocks and drinking water the
communities want shell to pay
compensation and clean up the area the
company says their case has no legal
standing
environmentally say the situation in the
two communities is director if you go by
that standard they said that the
groundwater impact there is 900 times
above who standard so it's killer now
and you have a spica Benzene we know how
leather how killer Benzene is
lawyers from the community claim shell
wants to delay Tuesday's hearing for
another two years to wear down the
villages and eventually have the case
thrown out
and that could have wider implications
the case is seen as a test as to whether
multinationals can be held accountable
for the actions of their overseas
subsidiaries Ahmad Idris Al Jazeera or
Gale